[Música]
economía en directo América de France 24
Jorge Hurtado con nosotros en el estudio
Jorge bienvenido buena mañana de
miércoles vamos a iniciar comentando
sobre el costo de vida en Reino Unido
Así es que los precios continúan su
espiral ascendente en Reino Unido la
inflación anual de septiembre fue del
10,1% impulsada por los precios de los
alimentos Los Altos costos de la energía
y la incertidumbre política que se vive
ahí la tasa de inflación anual
nuevamente fue la más alta desde 1982
igualando el ritmo marcado en el mes de
julio en septiembre los precios se
vieron impulsados al alza por los
alimentos por el costo de los alimentos
y en menor medida el costo de los
restaurantes y hoteles ahí solamente el
precio de los alimentos aumentó un
14,5% el mes pasado respecto al año
anterior es la mayor subida anual en más
de 40 años según la oficina Nacional de
estadísticas esta subida aumenta las
expectativas de que el banco de
Inglaterra suba los tipos de con mayor
rapidez en su lucha por devolver la
inflación al objetivo del 2%. el dato
pondrá también en apuros al nuevo
responsable del tesoro después de que el
plan económico del gobierno hiciera
tambalear a los mercados financieros el
mes pasado el nuevo ministro de finanzas
Jeremy home dijo que el gobierno va a
dar prioridad a ayudar a los más
vulnerables al tiempo que ofrece una
estabilidad económica más amplia Jorge
continuamos hablando de la inflación
pero ahora en eurozona y en la Unión
Europea la agencia de datos del bloque
eurostars confirmó que la subida de los
precios de la energía continúa
reflejándose En los niveles
inflacionarios la tasa de inflación
interanual de la eurozona aumentó en
ocho décimas en septiembre ahora se
ubica en
9,9% anual hace un año la tasa estaba en
el 3,4% en los países de la moneda única
por su parte en la Unión Europea se
ubicó en 10,9% en septiembre frente al
10,1% de agosto países como Francia
Malta y Finlandia con las tasas de
inflación anual más bajas mientras que
otros como Estonia lituania y letonia
fueron las más altas allí la energía
subió 4,19 puntos porcentuales seguido
de la Alimentación el alcohol y el
tabaco que subió 2,4 puntos y los
servicios que subieron un 1,80 puntos el
Centroamérica se reveló una encuesta
sobre la adopción del bitcoin en El
Salvador y es que hay que recordar que
el mes pasado septiembre precisamente
fue cuando El Salvador cumplió un año de
tener el bitcoin como moneda en curso
legal una reciente encuesta de la
universidad centroamericana reveló que
el 65% de la población opina que el
bitcoin ha sido un fracaso mientras otro
16,5% lo considera un éxito en una
escala del 0 al 10 la población calificó
en promedio un 4,6 la decisión del
presidente nayib bukelele de implementar
El bitcoin como moneda en curso legal un
dato más interesante Raúl es que el 71%
de los encuestados dijo que el gobierno
no debería seguir gasta fondos públicos
para comprar bitcoin o sea solamente Dos
de cada 10 salvadoreños apoya esta
decisión a los encuestados se les
preguntó también si este año han usado
bitcoin un 24% dijo que sí y otros 75%
lo negó la encuesta resaltó como la
implementación de esta criptomoneda ha
aumentado el riesgo país la deuda
pública salvadoreña y mantiene
enfrentado al Estado salvadoreño con los
principales organismos de financiación a
nivel internacional el presidente nayib
bukele ordenó la compra de casi
2.400 bitcoin en lo que va de este año y
según los cálculos de fondos del Estado
El Salvador ha gastado más de 100
millones de dólares para comprarlos
según el gobierno el bitcoin ha generado
turismo y comienza a traer inversión
extranjera a ese país centroamericano
bueno Jorge nos vamos al norte de
América en Estados Unidos la
probabilidad de una recesión va en
aumento bueno Esto según las
predicciones de múltiples medios de
comunicación estadounidense por ejemplo
según una recesión en Estados Unidos es
inevitable en los próximos 12 meses esto
según su modelo de proyecciones la
probabilidad pasó del 65% al 100%
recientemente de Wall Street journal
sitúa la probabilidad de una recesión en
los próximos 12 meses en el 63%. la
causa principal es la agresiva política
monetaria de aumentar los tipos de
interés de parte de la reserva Federal
que Precisamente es ponerle costo al
dinero para desacelerar la economía a
propósito y tratar de bajar la inflación
la agencia de calificación internacional
fitch advirtió que la inflación y los
aumentos de los tipos de interés a gran
escala llevarán a Estados Unidos a una
recesión leve al estilo de los años 90
vamos a ver entonces qué va a pasar
estos temores de recesión están llevando
grandes empresas Jorge a recordar
algunos puestos y es que según axios
Microsoft despidió esta semana al menos
a mil empleados en varias divisiones de
la empresa estos despidos afectaron al
menos al 1% de la total de Microsoft que
era de unos 221 mil Trabajadores al 30
de junio la empresa había dicho en julio
que se habían eliminado un pequeño
número de puestos y que aumentaría su
planilla más adelante varias empresas
tecnológicas como meta que dirige
Instagram Facebook WhatsApp Y también
Twitter y Snapchat también han despedido
personal y redujeron las contrataciones
en los en los últimos meses a medida que
el crecimiento económico mundial se
ralentiza debido a esta subida de los
tipos de interés a nivel global el
aumento de la inflación Y por supuesto
la crisis energética en Europa Jorge
como siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda
la información económica más adelante
más economía nosotros ahora vamos a
hablar con Rodrigo sedano de toda la
actualidad deportiva aquí en directo
América
[Música]